questo è il bambino che era stato
congelato nel primo capitolo
ognuno sta avendo quello che si meritava
giusto padre ho capito benvenuti
genitori oggi il nuovissimo episodio di
giochiamo alle 3 di notte a questa
accettiamo oggi al 99 lo scherzo
episodio vi è piaciuto tantissimo in cui
abbiamo giocato al granny babbo natale
come scriveva sempre più altri ancora
berlino vuole avere il centro
dell'attenzione
poi abbiamo giocata scheri teacher e
abbiamo giocato a dei fili nun ci avete
richiesto in tantissimi nei commenti di
giocare a questo nuovo gioco che si
chiama ice scream la taglio pazzo e
abbiamo visto che è uscito è uscito sia
il primo che il secondo
quindi il secondo ice cream il gelataio
pazzo vino non si mangia tuta velino si
mangerebbe anche il gelataio quando la
sete un bel mi piace se volete una terza
parte di giochiamo alle 3 di notte
se questo leader aggiunge 10 mila mi
piace faremo anche una terza parte ai
giochi che si consigliate voi nei
commenti qui di iscriversi con i miei
commenti si fa se no poi mi sono visto
gli offesi motti sembra la pace
stringersi alla
versione normale e guardati intorno e
muovendo il dito nello schermo mi
ricorda un po il nano ovvero guarda alla
finestra etica intera è quello in
giornata meglio alla testa da magna
ultimo lì se vuoi provare il nostrano a
modena nella congelato oddio ma è
veramente inquietante questo gelataio la
presa dentro la camioncino quel ragazzo
ha bisogno di aiuto trova l'accordo da
ordanini a casa diretti per per cento
regione la strada ok poverino dobbiamo
andare a salvarlo allora un accordo nel
cassetto qua non mi può andare forse
questo qua e non c'è niente
enel è solo un altro vecchietto allora
forse qua ecco allora prendiamo la ok
potete di caricarli la finestra
allora devo gettare la tenuta la fede si
terra ok ho messo la corda puoi
interagire con la finestra ma devo
scendere così può direbbe a ok ok
affetto usiamo in strada ma io ho paura
che fai attenzione c'è scritto non devi
essere visto o sarà in pericolo
ok ti puoi nascondere in questa è la
cuccia del cane
[Musica]
e caduto una canzoncina che gli è caduto
un block notes andiamo a prenderlo ok
come capitale paura che paura devi
prende vediamolo è una mappa aiuto sto
tornando nascondiamoci ok aspetta
sorgerà a dire che dovevo fare ad ok e
non ghiacciolo un gelato non so magari
ognuno ha un gusto ecco adesso lavorando
anche questo quando ma
[Musica]
ok non st eccolo sta andando lì molto
sentiti i rumori che ammira sarà il
cattivo e li devi andare proprio li
aspetta che faccia il giro fra il giro
davanti a fiumicino
adesso adesso corre dietro devi andare
vai apre ma io cosa devo fare qui quindi
la testa
qui cosa che qui l'altro quello grigio
sì no no no marco venuto a breve non
posso neanche liberarlo perché non ha la
chiave è questa la mappa adesso sono
accaduto di nuovo ma lui dov'è prova a
vedere dall'altra parte camioncino che
si è mai accaduta la mappa di aiuto
prendendo a campione
sappiamo che non arrivi 4 non è arriva
come
[Musica]
allora non mi sembra che la massa stia
così ma lui l'ha fatta cadere a terra e
poi io l'ho preso e quindi dov'è stata
forse devo aspettare che la faccia
cadere nuovamente appunto perché se
trovi girasoli noi conoscendo iat io mi
nascondo non si sa mai
ecco come ho fatto a non tacerla
prendila sbrigati aprì la porta
ok ti la mettiamo la mappa e andiamo
alla caffetteria si era molto arrabbiato
[Musica]
sta contando dov'è
la portata a casa
allora ci dice che qui possiamo va bene
non ci interessa
lo scopriremo da soli a guardare
purtroppo sono presenti nei cassonetti
scappa scappa scappa scappa accogliamo
le onde arriviamo che vincino abbiamo
solo due vite che ci mancano
c'è rinchiuso dentro il frigo perché
devi scappare alla porta era aperta
mamma voleva trasformarsi in chissà
quale gelato ma non c'è niente questo
frigorifero e speravo di trovare
qualcosa da mangiare
non è il momento per momento del
mangiare uno think gela tutti
trasformerebbe genoa tu ti senti allora
proviamo ad abbassarci per vedere se
troviamo altri altre cose che ho detto
dobbiamo chiudere questo è matto
senza la voce ma lui non c'è né posso
nascondere in una scatola da un pezzo
aiutava stacchiamo la corrente
comunque secondo me a te trasformerebbe
in un
magnum noccioline
invece io sarei tipo un look in ghiaccio
lo scrivete nei commenti qual è il
vostro gelato preferito e che buono
magnum anche luke buonissimi poi mattina
ok abbiamo visto dei suggerimenti che
dobbiamo cercare dello scotch del nastro
isolante dobbiamo cercare per unire
vinca lui stava là dietro non visto
quindi lui ci sta osservare lo sta
osservando
ecco l'ho visto nel cassetto
adesso andiamo a collegare i cavi dove
offerto da scappare
beh dovete votare e qui si va verso la
porta o cristo
vogliamo nella caffetteria visto che sta
tornando abbiamo doccia voli ma se non
abbiamo la chiave propri non andiamo da
un'altra parte andiamo al playground
ma egli ruby sono sempre il fiore
furgoncino capisco dunque molto
inquietante anche questo zoo
sì forse è pure un po di piano un
pochettino più divertente rispetto agli
altri c'è più cosa da fare perché c'è
più e ha preso continuità abbiamo
nessuna
dubbi di roma si rinchiude nuovamente in
quel posto che mi 16 eh eh sì beh non
dovrebbe essere così difficile da uscire
allora mangia collegati detto da far
aprire la porta che si apre così
sicuramente funzionerà questa tiralo
come si tira così no reale adesso come
faccio a saltare salta no clicca clicca
ma non è giusto
ma abbiamo ancora una possibilità mi sa
di sì sono stato catturato il libero
vite ancora quindi abbiamo ancora una
possibilità quindi in tutto quanto sono
tre o quattro ha di nuovo rimesso lavoro
maledetto freddo prendilo forse ce la
facciamo questa volta stiamo attenti a
non uscire quando lui esatto togliamo al
chiodo william anche un altro chiodo a
chiodo attenzione stato un altro settore
di trafugare primi a casa vuole
trasbordare meno uno
forse ora ci trasforma in gelato vediamo
in che gelato citra stato lui a roth
quindi no ci ha portato nella sua casa
quello lì c è lui gigante e quindi che
dobbiamo fare adesso
neymar ha l'imprimatur gelati ecco che
può così freddo adesso che facciamo è
finito siamo diventati bettini gelato
voglio vedere in che genere mobile anche
giornate si trasforma chiama ad ice
cream due vediamo che la parte 2
ok erico quale secondo capitolo heist
crime 2
vediamo un po come questo è il bambino
che era stato congelato nel primo
capitolo e queste sono forse gli altri
bambini che sono state funzionate quale
lo sta disegnando molto anni 80 si
infatti è anche la musica stringersi in
apple sarà scritto sul computer non
giocare con me da pizzolato aj styles
veneto giocare i ragazzi si sono
nascoste in un posto segreto offre
[Musica]
trasformata in un gelato ok
cosa devo fare dobbiamo uscire dalla
finestra letto a pensavo che potevo
andare a dormire visivo coperte se ti
eri continua torna la troppa ansia
allora secondo me fermiamoci qui a
nasconderci un attimo ma lui non c'è
tutto natalizia durante l'albero di
natale
ecco scappa scappa stato aspetta
scappare quando ok
proviamo ad uscire sì non penso che ci
vede adesso non detto tutto la mappa
vediamo di trovare la mappa qui non c'è
cosa qualcosa per terra corpi quindi
molto simile per ora si sta dentro
street bridge dimentica mappa mai
sarebbe mai mai un mese fa
ok ti mandiamo cimitero come che poi
erano tante sentirci eviterebbe
inquietantissimo non era proprio belli e
andare al cimitero con il camioncino dei
gelati e ci sono queste guarda gli altri
sono 60 smi forse sono le anime dei
bambini che ha preso non capisco perché
sono così diverso dagli altri
in realtà non mangia così il tanto per
essere così grosso recentemente ho
mangiato un po di gelato i compagni
dicono ciccione ciccione perdessimo così
diverso non voglio essere così boarino
lo stanno pulito tanto stiamo arrivando
con il camioncino dei gelati nel
cimitero una mia età l'inquietante qua
anche perché buio
apriamo la porta che cosa vuole il
signore che fa isolati il gelataio ok a
ricaricare apriamo questa forza di
ronchi successo misura di usare la porta
che cosa cerca a fare
c'era qualcosa una colonna ma puoi
mettere qualcosa
e arrivato a presi il gelataio ci ha
portato nuovamente nel suo scantinato
già chiuso dentro il frigo quindi
dobbiamo c'è una chiave dobbiamo
scappare d'acqua per riuscire poi a
tornare al cimitero o non lo so parte
meglio andare dall'altra parte per più
di evitare ora troppo inquietante
sì decisamente
forse bisogna aprire la finestra sarà
scritto dalla parte di dietro eccola lì
maledetto ok al guardiamo al circo circo
andiamo via
certo questi bambini che già sono qui la
pivot luca 15 mag
ci siamo arrivati al circo almeno è un
po meno inquietante del cimitero force
si va bene adesso di aiuto circo anche
cao corri corri a mamma perché sei
camminando e doloso brioso aver ricevuto
storto
pacquiao tolosa quanto rumore facciamo
ogni volta ci spostiamo ora mentre
dentro e chi osa chiuso mannaggia o no
non mi viene che ci sono giusto lì io
scappo capisco pac
[Musica]
ok qui sicuro non si può fare devi avere
le identifica e shawn caldo per entrare
quindi dobbiamo trovarla da qualche
parte secondo me dentro i tendoni del
circolo terre ma non è facile andare lì
perché lì anche questo usa ma il tutto
non si può fare nulla questa sera c'è
qualcosa dall'altra parte dalla tua
parte ii anno era solo una bandierina
proviamo ad andare da qualche altra
parte degli undici dice cura i piatti
sarà questo gatto no no no io sono stata
una mamma
[Musica]
ok è stata sopra dell'immagine o chi
ride forte senso di realtà dobbiamo
provare interesse
se facciamo una ultima la migliore non
ha voglia forzare scritto allora vediamo
che cosa ci fosse qualcuno incastrato
vento dice cat food cibo per gatti
prendilo che se dobbiamo trovare il
gatto sarà un meglio prendere il cibo
per gatti
no quindicenne e su micio micio micio
due temi ciò forse bisogna lasciare il
cibo per gatti per prenderlo come
sorpreso a tra loro abbiamo solo due
vite e dobbiamo nuovamente scappare wow
c'è scritto che il rote sta dormendo e
se fa il rumore lo svegli come facciamo
a scendere da tre salta c'era proprio
scritta di fare rumore allora andiamo al
cinema
abbiamo solo una vita descritto scritto
sento la sua voce che si è fregato
cambia niente se ne aspettiamo in mezzo
alla macchina dietro il camion ha
assorbito il gatto si no
se dobbiamo trovarlo quasi mai a berlino
stai calmo le sette toga solo di subito
entrare sicuramente in quella da setta
mia forse dobbiamo prendere il caos
berlino si sta profumo della porta qua
hanno questo la cassetta degli attrezzi
fine c'è qualcosa che pezzo di ferro per
rompere
scappa scappa scappa ho sentito il gatto
anche io marley non lo sta sentendo la
sta cercando
ma scordiamoci ce la scordiamo dove ce
la scordiamo prestarono vedo non vedo
neanche io non ho qui ho paura che mi
prenda ok non dovrebbe esserci più
non lo vedo che proviamo entrare dentro
la casetta qui non si può andare da
nessuna parte però no questo non ha
scollegato
no è sempre in mezzo alle scalate scappa
da dove vado a dentro me posso
nascondere che allora siamo riusciti a
scappare dal frigo purtroppo non stava
registrando quale cellulare e abbiamo
deciso di andare al cimitero nuovamente
anche se il più inquietante è molto
interessante ero ancora il martello bene
prima che si sia utile chiaro mamma mia
scappa scappa questo non so dove andare
no no no no non qui non qui non qui
perché non perché questo è un vicolo
cieco ma si renderà di nuovo a destra
adesso per lì e li paralizza la sotto
gamba 4a vorrà dire qualcosa mettere le
candele cosa padre tu sei stato la mia
unica famiglia
non ho mai incontrato mia madre ma non
mi è mai interessato
quindi questo è il padre io e te eravamo
un grande team
ho sempre voluto essere un gelataio
grande come te speravo che avessi avuto
più tempo per me ho avuto così tanti
problemi a scuola
ora sono più grande mi prendo cura di me
stessa ognuno sta avendo quello che si
meritava giusto padre ho capito quel
bambino di cui era visto la storia e lui
si rodi gelataio il bambino che veniva
preso in giro a scuola
ops e il bambino che veniva presenti la
scuola perché la sul suo appello e
quindi lui si sta vendicando così sta
vendica dopo tutti i bambini e tutti i
bambini li sta congelando per vendicarsi
del hanno trattato male a scuola e
l'hanno bollata la vita col martello in
mano che si facciano questo mestiere è
quello che vorrei ora parlare corrotto o
sono riusciti a nascondere dietro
vorrei dirgli non è questo il modo il
modo di superare vinto i traumi
infantili devi parlarne con qualcuno ma
non puoi vendicarti così e quindi anche
il padre era un gelataio
ma se facciamo andare a qua cosa cela
dietro come ci devo trovare delle
candele da mettere potete per fare ma lo
puoi prendere da mettere nella sua tomba
chi è questo il caso sta curando la
fiammata è domandato è infatti devo
ancora trovare questo gatto
sono cosa di sportello
tutto pare candele qua sono già passata
l'incarto progetto questa cosa so che
abbiamo visto cosa le nostre vite
ferrara supera interessanti della
maggiore è molto interessante quesito
volete che continuiamo a giocare ad ice
cream lasciato un bel mi piace questo
video 10 mila mi piace gioco
continueremo a giocare al gioco
scriveteci per tutti i vostri consigli
trucchi eco lanciato nei commenti
e ora vi lasciamo quota caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite lipu
revisione